McLovin working from home today air
quotations set the scene at home there
McLovin okay I am wearing sweat pants
and a sweatshirt which is lovely
my daughter is running up to the screen
and talking to you as you speak during
the show so and I said I was babysitting
and I realized when you guys brought
that up and saying what you can't
babysit your own kids no you can't your
yeah your parenting well not really I'm
doing a pretty bad job basically my
older daughter did all the morning stuff
and I sort of walked around cluelessly
Shella but everyone's surviving but I
miss you guys this is a little you know
I want to jump in now looking but it's
stains being at home you know what we
were saying we could get used to this
makes a lot roomier for fritzy in the
back Joris quickly sold out I figure he
was the one I would miss me the one that
had the partition I was blocking with
you oh my gosh
what kind of pliers you got for us okay
actually I'm calling with one of
paulie's options which I like is it over
yes or no about a finals okay what else
okay
what's more likely now I sweep or six
games okay I'm saying well thanks
because that was my prediction in the
beginning so stay with that I don't
think we're going to have a sweep okay
this you sort of tease at the end of
last time I do you consider game three a
must-win situation for Cleveland yes yes
or no yes okay you can go out over in
there yeah yep okay is it worse to be
crossed over or dunked on in today's NBA
I think it's worse to be crossed over is
the last night no no I just think
sometimes when you get by the way that
was a double dribble with Steph Curry on
the Bron James that I had another
question did should they start calling
traveling more in the NBA or sure they
keep it as it I think it's too late
they're not going to start calling that
I
think the the palming part they should
call it's pretty egregious but I feels
like when you're breaking somebody down
breaking ankles crossing somebody over
it we're used to guys being dunked on
the whole crossover thing we didn't see
very much of that until gosh Ivarsson or
Tim Hardaway those are the guys that
were breaking your ankles but now it
feels like you want somebody to just
tumble down you know you want Humpty
Dumpty to fall off the wall what else
you have okay
is Albert Pujols his career disappointed
yes or no no no as a totality you don't
find a little bit of a letdown
well there is a letdown but he had a
pretty incredible 10-year run there and
if you look at where he was drafted to
make the major leagues and then have
this kind of career he's going to be a
first-ballot hall-of-famer no I mean he
I don't think he's very good now he's
got a lot of RBIs not considered you
know he may be one of the worst DHS in
the American League but no I would say
that this has been a pretty incredible
career for Albert pools at 37 do you
think he can reach 700 home runs yeah I
think if you do the math if and they
broke it down if you were in the next
four years that he would be able to do
this but you know you're going to need a
pretty good run here the rest of this
year and you know have to have 25 or 30
a couple of those years but I think he
can do it and I think baseball were
reckoned nationally he'll be recognized
to be just a 700 for some reason 600 and
not a big deal it feels like okay my
final option okay you do you miss having
McLovin in that chair today yes or no
for the nation
I know internally how you guys both
because there's limited number resources
down a bathroom so it's probably
convenient that I'm not there today but
nationally I we could put it out there
this is a strong word McLovin mmm is
there a softer word
did you notice McLovin women in the
chair how about that that could be I
would I could be closer I would prefer
to have McLovin in the chair okay good
all right
back to your daughter's okay thanks
thanks McLovin thank you
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience